[Music]
now i'm sure you've heard of greek myth
with its tales of zeus and the olympian
gods or norse legend with its skaldic
sagas about thought loki and the frost
giants
but what about baltic paganism and
obscure mythology from the frozen
forests of northern europe featuring the
storm god perconas who hunts the forest
of latvia in search of his one-eyed
rival velenats or how about the supreme
deity dievance and how he accidentally
formed humanity out of his saliva
long story enter your log cabin grab
your pint of grass and a healthy amount
of potato dumplings it's time to
introduce you to the mythology of the
baltics europe's last pagan religion
the baltic region is in northern europe
situated below scandinavia and finland
straddling the aptly named baltic sea
here lie the small countries of
lithuania latvia and estonia about half
of the region is blanketed in pine
forest the trees seem to continue
endlessly and you can go days without
seeing any sign of human life the land
here is also very flat causing murky
bogs and swamps to develop winters are
known to be harsh from december to march
temperatures can dip well below freezing
these nations are some of the wildest
regions in europe as well as the least
populated people have lived in the
baltics for millennia mostly in networks
of loosely connected tribes until the
middle ages they had little contact with
the outside world as a result
christianity was the last to reach them
starting in the 12th century the church
launched a great northern crusade and
brought christianity into the region
through violence and warfare after the
brutal conflict and the shedding of much
innocent blood many natives renounced
their religion in favor of christianity
others however held on to their
ancestral beliefs and continued to
worship the old gods in secret it's time
you outlined the mythology and beliefs
of baltic paganism the thing is however
there's no strict list of deities or
centralized pantheon much of what we
know about baltic religion is from
outside sources particularly crusaders
we therefore only have a rough idea
about the beliefs and religion of this
ancient people but an idea nonetheless
prepare for my bad pronunciation of
baltic gods here goes
let's start at the beginning of the
universe with divas the primordial
creator divas existed before anything
else existed there's no account of how
he came to be simply put he was always
there sometimes dievis is depicted
without a body just an intangible
universal concept other accounts give
him the form of an old traveling beggar
who roams the forests alone exploring
his creation in silence and solitude
divas is the lithuanian word for god a
bit like how in english god can either
mean the god of the bible or simply any
deity a really interesting tidbit
however is that the lithuanian word
deavas is related to a bunch of other
languages and their word for god the
latin word for god is deus the greek
word for god is deos even as far away as
ancient india the sanskrit word for god
is deva all of these sound very similar
to our baltic god divas this ancient
linguistic connection may show just how
old baltic paganism may really be
divas is not the only god abound after
he created the universe he brought forth
a pantheon of other gods first up is
mara the earth goddess also known as
mother earth she's the patron goddess of
motherhood and breastfeeding as well as
the protector of the environment when
people die it is said mara takes their
bodies back into the soil while divas
takes their souls up into the sky
when christianity arrived in the baltics
mara was confused with the virgin mary
perhaps due to a similarity in name in
fact across the baltics today there's an
uncomfortable fusion between
christianity and old paganism in
northern lithuania there's a site known
as the hill of crosses on a single hill
there are 100 000 statues and effigies
dedicated to the virgin mary now
although it's a christian monument it
certainly has a pre-christian feel to it
it bears resemblance to the many carved
wooden idols across the region that were
once dedicated to the goddess mara i'll
let you decide on this one
after creating mara divas then created
talia velez the smith god he's
responsible for technology and
innovation and helped dievas craft the
universe one of his first jobs was to
forge the sun once televellist finished
crafting it he threw it up into the
night sky and it illuminated the earth
the sun was then personified into saule
the sun goddess not long after creating
saole televeles made menueuo the moon
god the two fell in love and got married
ruling the night and day as a couple
between them they had thousands of
children the stars now manuel was not a
faithful husband to saleh not long into
the marriage he had an affair with
austrian a the morning star saole found
out about this and was horrified
especially since austrine may or may not
have been their daughter as a punishment
every month menuho is cut up into pieces
and stuck back together later on
resembling the various stages of the
lunar cycle
let's leave this marital crisis for now
and explore how the first humans came to
be according to myth humanity came about
from a drop of dievis's spit having
wiped it from his mouth the spit
droplets splashed down onto the earth
and from them the first humans sprang
forth in this story humans were a
complete accident and divers doesn't
really seem to care about them unlike
the bible humans are not the privileged
custodians of the earth we're just well
saliva
[Music]
up next is the strongest of all the gods
and the de facto leader his name is
perconas the god of thunder he is
depicted as a giant bearded man wielding
an axe and riding a strider chariot
wheeled by two goats as he roams across
the sky thunder and lightning flash in
his wake now this god might sound
familiar either through thor from
norsmith or zeus from greek myth this
does not seem to be a coincidence across
a bunch of ancient european religions
there's an archetypal figure who rules
in the heavens and creates lightning
some scholars have called this person
the sky father perconas is the baltic
interpretation of this sky father
archetype and is distantly related to
thor and zeus
perchnas is constantly on the hunt he's
searching for velenas the evil god of
the underworld some myths depict velenas
as a one-eyed prophetic trickster
responsible for all the world's woes a
bit like the norse figure loki in that
regard velanas resides in lowland places
like bogs and swamps so he's very much
at home in the baltic region in order to
hide from perconas velenas will
transform into rocks trees and even
sometimes as other people
[Music]
as seen already with mara and felinas a
number of the baltic gods are closely
associated with mortality but none as
much as giltne the goddess of death
itself she is depicted as a thin pale
woman robed in white and she could be
found roaming graveyards licking corpses
with her long tongue
if you don't like the sound of giltne
and who would you may prefer her sister
lima the goddess of fate luck and
pregnant women when a baby is born she
is the one who will decide their destiny
what they will do whom they will love
and most importantly how they will die
like it or not in baltic mythology
everything that happens in your life has
already been determined by lima in
ancient days those wanting protection
and safety will pray to lima with the
hope that she will grant them with good
luck nowadays however protection is
something you don't want to leave to
chance especially when it comes to the
internet that's why this video is
sponsored by nordvpn vpn stands for
virtual private network it's a useful
tool that encrypts your internet traffic
and hides your ip address and virtual
location it's basically an internet
cloaking device meaning that third
parties like cyber criminals can't spawn
you whilst you're online with nordvpn
you can log into your accounts make bank
transfers and shop online without
needing to worry about anyone stealing
your data there are plenty of other
benefits of getting a vpn aside from
internet safety one i particularly like
is the ability to stream shows that
aren't even in your own country nordvpn
allows you to change your virtual
location with over 60 countries to
choose from so if you want to take your
internet security back into your own
hands and access all the other great
perks on offer go to nordvpn.com forward
slash hotel argo or use code ho chilaga
to get 73 off the first two years plus
four additional months for free
as well as all the interesting gods and
goddesses baltic paganism is full of
monsters and spirits here are a few of
the most famous the most common
supernatural beings are the aitfaras
nature spirits they have the ability to
shape-shift and transform into a variety
of different things most commonly it's
snakes roosters and even fire many
however can be found as trees or rocks
within each one is supposed to be an eye
terror who grant you protection provided
you offer a small sacrifice of course
and that's why there are so many sacred
groves across the baltics there are
plenty of shrines dedicated to the
largest of trees or the heaviest of
boulders on the other end however there
are the baubai they are small impish
creatures who work on behalf of velenas
their job is to haunt children
particularly the ones who have been
badly behaved deep in the forest you'll
also find raganos the baltic witch once
a beautiful human woman she's now become
wretched and hag-like ragonos is known
to curse unwary townsfolk by turning
them into frogs pigs and tree stumps on
the darkest day of the year the winter
solstice raganos is most active so many
advise to stay indoors or to light a
large bonfire to scare her away
[Music]
by the 14th century baltic paganism had
been replaced with christianity however
these ancient beliefs stuck around a bit
and never quite went away one attempt to
bring back the paganism of old is the
remover religion practitioners of
removal believe in all the gods and
myths that we've seen so far as was done
since ancient times they make fire
offerings to the supreme deity de avas
and maintain the forest groves home to
the aitfaras today the religion is
seeking to establish itself as an
officially recognized faith in lithuania
and they're making significant steps in
potentially bringing back ancestral
beliefs in the baltics
baltic paganism is a fantastic mythology
rich with history and steeped in magic i
can only hope to have given you a rough
introduction to this diverse belief
system if you wish to do further reading
on this topic i've added a bunch of
links in the description below we'll
leave the mythology of the baltics for
now but i want to turn the question on
to you the viewer what obscure mythology
do you want to see next let me know all
the overlooked and underrated
mythologies that interest you
who knows i might cover it in a future
video
hey thanks for watching this video i
really hope you enjoyed this one if
you'd like to see more why not subscribe
a like and a comment also go a really
long way
[Music]
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye
[Music]